merci d'être avec nous sur LCP Public
Sénat pour une nouvelle émission de
Parlement Hebdo le meilleur de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour à tous bonjour Michael
on va revenir sur cette alliance
hétéroclite au Sénat UMP radicaux et
Front de Gauche se sont associés pour
faire repousser l'examen de la réforme
territoriale ils ont trouvé une faille
l'étude d'impact de cette réforme le
Conseil constitutionnel a maintenant
huit jours pour se prononcer sur la
validité du texte cette semaine
également le collectif budgétaire était
en discussion à l'Assemblée au programme
des baisses d'impôts pour plus de 3
millions de ménages le gouvernement
subit des tirs croisés des écologistes
et des socialistes fondament aura-t-il
la majorité pour faire voter ce texte
réponse mardi prochain et puis une page
d'histoire avec le centenaire de la
guerre de 14-18 la Chambre des députés a
siéger pendant cette période nous étions
alors sous la 11e législature un tiers
des représentants du peuple sont partis
au front une exposition à l'Assemblée
revient sur cet engagement
et avec nous pour commenter toute cette
actualité Jean-Jacques Urvoas bonjour
bonjour député PS du Finistère président
de la commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale actualité très riche très
chargée on va évidemment vous demander
de commenter toute cette actualité mais
il y a une traduction dans cette
émission c'est que les parlementaires
dressent votre portrait on les écoute et
vous réagissez c'est un Breton il est
têtu il travaille et il va droit devant
lui et il s'est labouré son chemin il
fait l'unanimité à la présidence de la
commission des lois c'est un président
compétent je regrette parfois dans
certains débats politiques
sont pas d'ailleurs directement liés à
sa compétence mais sur d'autres sujets
qu'il ait été un peu raide ou agressif
dans ses expressions très bon Président
respectueux de l'opposition des
procédures législatives très à l'écoute
et très compétent vraiment moi je ne
peux que je peux dans l'opposition je ne
peux que me louer de Jean-Jacques urbois
rigoureux
exigeant
et beaucoup d'humour il manque peut-être
parfois un petit peu de courage pour
prendre certaines positions et il
pourrait peut-être de ce point de vue
être plus ouvert aux propositions de
l'opposition être parfois un petit peu
plus critique avec les propositions la
majorité
globalement c'est satisfaisant j'aime
bien votre tradition faudra m'inviter
souvent d'accord c'est agréable
têtu comme un Breton oui enfin c'est une
facilité mais c'est vrai comme je pense
que tout comme tous les parlementaires
qui sont ici on a des convictions un peu
raide oui quand on ne respecte pas
justement ce qui fait le sel de cette
maison c'est à dire d'abord la
courtoisie l'argumentation quand on
essaie de développer et quand on se
contente de faciliter la Commission à la
chance elle a beaucoup de travail les
parlementaires qui sont choisis d'y être
et je suis effectivement assez exigeant
du fait que l'on produise de nous le
meilleur il y a pas longtemps dans le
remaniement il y a quelques mois en tout
cas vous étiez pressenti
point d'interrogation pour un poste de
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
pas trop déçu non moi je suis très
heureux là où je suis je pense que je
suis très utile à Manuel Valls là où je
suis
l'avenir n'a écrit nulle part alors
lundi on reparle de l'écotaxe mais de
l'appeler plus Ecotaxe
pH de transit c'est le nom du nouveau
dispositif présenté par le gouvernement
après des moins de polémique la mesure a
été introduite dans le collectif
budgétaire par le biais d'un amendement
qu'est-ce qui change quelles sont les
résultats Marie laba nous en dit plus
matinaux a finalement tranché les
portiques et cotax c'est terminé après
plusieurs mois de protestation et une
bataille sans concession entre les
bonnets rouges et le gouvernement ce
dernier a donc choisi une version
édulcorée de l'écotax au 1er janvier
2015 ils seront ainsi remplacés par des
péages de transit pour les poids lourds
de plus de 3 tonnes et demi il est
logique que les poids lourds notamment
les plus importants ce qui dépasse trois
tonnes et demi paie une partie de
l'usage des infrastructures puisque la
plupart d'entre eux notamment sur les
axes de transit internationaux ne payent
rien calculer selon un tarif moyen de 13
centimes d'euros par kilomètre modulable
en fonction de la distance parcourue du
niveau de pollution du camion et de son
nombre d'essieu cette nouvelle redevance
rencontre cependant déjà un problème
majeur elle devrait rapporter moins que
l'écotaxe au lieu du milliard d'euros
annuellement escompté les péages de
transit ne devraient engendrer
qu'environ 550 millions d'euros on
revient sur une position
que la taxe poids lourd qui avait été
votée à l'unanimité qui est une
proposition ambitieuse on le réduit de
moitié évidemment les écologistes ne
peuvent pas suivre une telle proposition
il faut expliquer aux Français que les
quotas sur les poids lourds c'est pas un
impôts c'est une taxe sauf que
maintenant les Français vont payer un
impôts c'est la société ecomouv' qui
devrait être chargée de récolter la
nouvelle taxe une façon de mettre fin en
conflit qui l'opposait à l'État depuis
que celui-ci avait suspendu le contrat
pour la construction des portiques
écotax en compensation du manque à
gagner il devrait aussi verser à la
société près de 850 millions d'euros
cette question ainsi que celle de la
prise de participation au capital des
comouve sont toujours en négociation
alors Jean-Jacques urboz le pH de
transit te rapportera près de deux fois
moins que l'écotaxe le manque à gagner
est important pour les collectivités
locales qui va payer la différence selon
vous d'abord c'est une bonne décision je
suis élu dans une région qui avait
combattu les portiques la Bretagne c'est
une bonne décision parce que ce qui
était avant n'était pas applicable parce
que
revient à la meilleure chose c'est à
dire qu'on parle du transit c'est-à-dire
toutes ces tous ces camions qui
évitaient de prendre les autoroutes qui
prennent des routes nationales et qui
utilisaient ces infrastructures c'est
normal qu'il paye le manque à gagner
pour l'Etat et bien on trouvera les
solutions moi je trouve que les sociétés
d'autoroute elles ont des magots dans
lesquelles on pourrait envisager de
prendre une cote-part pour entretenir
les infrastructures qu'utilisent
parfois les solutions les plus simples
sont les meilleures mais en attendant il
y a certains nombre de travaux de
grandes infrastructures qui restent en
sur le carreau aucune n'est abandonné le
ministre de l'Économie Michel Sapin la
dit l'autre jour tous les projets qui
sont en cours ne sont pas annulés donc
on peut les lisser dans le temps moi je
suis dans une région vous l'a rappelé
qui est très attachée aux
infrastructures parce que nous on a
évidemment un problème en permanence de
d'accès au centre de décision française
et européen donc on veut un TGV on veut
des routes gratuites donc on est
conscient de la du caractère compliqué
de tout cela mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que faut pas oublier l'essentiel
l'oublier l'essentiel c'est qu'on ne
choisit pas de vivre là où on a une
maison où on a un emploi aujourd'hui
pourquoi les vers sont pas contents
parce qu'ils sont cohérents avec eux
même ils sont ils considèrent qu'il y a
un certain nombre de coups qu'il faut
faire payer par des utilisateurs sauf
que la décision qui est prise par ces
golem Royal revient à la justesse eux
ils enveloppent ils font pardon ils
développent un point de vue général nous
on essaie d'appliquer ça à la réalité le
transit ça concerne pas toutes les
régions il y avait aucune région de
traiter tous des régions pareil une
raison parlant de traiter toutes les
régions pareil l'écotaxes devenus du pH
de transit avait suscité la colère des
bonnets rouges très actifs dans votre
circonscription aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que vous leur dites à ces beaux des
rouges pour qui cessent leur mouvement
honnêtement d'ailleurs j'ai constaté
qu'il n'avait pas protesté de manière
véhémente leur protestation aurait été
injustifiées dans la mesure où la
Bretagne n'est concerné que par l'axe
Saint-Lô rennante où là effectivement on
a du transit qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
le transit quand vous récupérez les
langoustines dans le Pays Bigouden quand
vous les amenez à Rungis je suis désolé
mais on peut pas les amener en train
donc il y a de la route et cette route
là il était anormal de taxer ceux qui
allait l'utiliser c'est vrai pour le
trou agroalimentaire c'est vrai pour la
collecte de lait ce sont des choses qui
pour nous représentent énormément
aujourd'hui oui mais d'ailleurs très
honnêtement ils l'ont bien compris les
dernières manifestations n'ont pas
rencontré un grand succès ce qui est
assez logique puisqu'il n'y avait pas de
raison que non on va passer au mardi si
vous voulez bien avec un cas dont on a
beaucoup parlé celui de Vincent Lambert
et le Conseil d'État a tranché les
décisions médicales d'arrêt des soins
qui maintenaient envie Vincent Lambert
et légal cette décision devrait avoir un
impact sur le plan législatif on se
dirige vers une modification de la loi
léonidétique de 2005 sur
l'accompagnement des malades en fin de
vie on va d'ailleurs écouter le député
Leonetti qui a été chargé d'une mission
par Manuel Valls
je salue cette décision qui conforte
bien sûr la loi de 2005 droit des
malades et fin de vie mais au-delà de la
décision juridique je salue aussi la
démarche du Conseil d'État qui a pris
des précautions en matière d'expertise
médicale sur le cas de Vincent Lambert
qui a pris aussi les précautions sur des
avis généraux sur les terminologies
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une obstination
déraisonnable qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
traitement qui n'a d'autre effet que le
maintien artificiel de la vie je
m'adresse au président de la commission
des lois 9 Français sur 10 selon un
sondage BVA favorable à l'euthanasie et
pourtant on a l'impression que le
gouvernement le président de la
République n'est vraiment pas pressé de
légiférer il faut pas être pressé de
légiférer sur des sujets comme cela
d'abord parce qu'il renvoie l'essentiel
c'est à dire ce que chacun d'entre nous
pense de l'humain je suis pas juriste
dans cette affaire parce que il n'y a
pas de droit à dire le Conseil d'État a
dit ce qu'il fallait faire il a donné
une définition de ce qu'est
l'obstination des raisonnable justement
je suis pas certain qu'il faille
préciser ça un parce que j'ai une
conviction justement parce que j'ai fait
du droit mon métier la loi ne peut pas
tout la loi ne peut pas se dire
constance oui la loi ne peut pas tout y
a il y a une part qui relève de ce que
chacun pense moi je pense beaucoup à la
femme de ce monsieur qui depuis 6 ans a
un mari qui est dans un état végétatif
et qui voit une partie de sa famille
pardon de le dire comme ça mais dont
j'ai le sentiment qu'elle s'obstine pour
des convictions qui n'ont pas grand
chose à voir avec la réalité du malade
on a on sent l'impuissance du du
législateur face à ces à ces questions
très sensibles aux frontières de la vie
et de la mort il y a une loi qui existe
la loi néonetti
Jean Leonetti a été chercher dans mon
écrire une autre que que peut apporter
une nouvelle loi qu'est-ce que je ne
suis pas certain qu'il faille justement
une nouvelle loi je ne suis pas certain
de ça très honnêtement je suis très
prudent sur ces sujets d'abord parce que
dans ma vie personnelle j'ai jamais été
confronté à ces questions et je pense
que quand on y est confronté on a un
regard qui a une densité que je n'ai pas
donc moi j'ai un recul sur cette affaire
de législateur parce que je le suis
momentanément mais quand même qu'est-ce
que la loi peut apporter de plus que
cette démo différents on sera toujours
ça le droit c'est jamais une histoire de
connaissance c'est toujours un acte
d'interprétation si vous comprend bien à
la classe Jean léonity son chargé d'une
mission dans le même doivent faire
évoluer cette loi léonétique mais vous
vous dites que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de raison de la changer je ne dis
pas ça ça serait encore trop mais
justement ça c'est encore trop ferme je
pourquoi pas réfléchir toujours vaut
mieux mieux générons un grand débat
public par exemple on en a déjà beaucoup
fait comme j'ai le sentiment que le
diagnostic est assez facilement posé
est-ce que c'est deux collègues qui
connaissent très très bien ce sujet qui
ont déjà travaillé ensemble est-ce
qu'ils peuvent encore affiner notre
réflexion collective acceptons-en
l'augure est-ce qu'il faut pour autant
déboucher sur une amélioration de la loi
peut-être si on n'est pas sûr pas sûr ça
risque aussi peut-être d'ouvrir un autre
débat on se rappelle du débat du mariage
pour tous qui avait évidemment fait
couper la France presque en deux là
aussi il peut y avoir aussi les gars
avec un autre front ça ne me dérange pas
moi je je n'ai pas peur des débats de
société parce que je trouve que ils font
ce que la société nous permet de
supporter donc il y a un degré
d'acceptation en tout cas regardons ça
avec beaucoup de sérénité ni mettons pas
de passion essayons d'y mettre le moins
les partisanes possible et regardons ça
parce que ce que c'est à dire qu'est-ce
qu'un homme
alors Jean-Jacques
on va reparler de politique avec une
nouvelle journée de tension à l'UMP
Christian Jacob est resté à la tête des
députés du groupe mais il a annoncé une
réforme du fonctionnement des finances
du groupe décisions après la révélation
d'un prêt de 3 millions d'euros
consentis par le groupe au parti
germandrieu Thibault Le Floch
le procédé n'a rien d'illégal mais les
explications étaient très attendues
réunion sous haute tension ce matin pour
les députés UMP avant le week-end
dernier aucun de ces parlementaires
n'était au courant que leur groupe avait
prêté 3 millions d'euros au parti très
endettés
responsabilité je pense pas avoir fait
d'erreur certains me reprochent
effectivement de dire tu aurais dû nous
le dire bon soit et d'autres
effectivement comprennent que si je
l'avais mis sur la place publique à ce
moment-là les banques ce serait
vraisemblablement retirées et le parti
explosait je pense que personne n'avait
intéresse que le parti explosion plus de
transparence avec un audit financier
demander à Gilles Carrez il sera aidé
par deux députés de son choix et à
l'avenir les députés souhaitent pouvoir
demander des comptes à un trésorier il
faut que ce trésorier à l'avenir nous
fasse une présentation régulière des
comptes au moins deux fois par an un
budget prévisionnel et puis ensuite
qu'on puisse vérifier l'exécution de ce
budget aujourd'hui plusieurs députés
s'interrogent encore sur les factures
réglées à la société à Lyon selon le
Canard Enchaîné entre 2008 et 2013 le
groupe des députés UMP aurait réglé pour
5,5 millions d'euros pour des
prestations dont la plupart des députés
n'ont jamais eu connaissance et savoir
que bigmalion a touché
parent sous Jacob enfin même pas sous
Copé c'était le double mais sous-jacob
Bygmalion touchait 600 000 euros
c'est-à-dire plus que la totalité des
cotisations de tous les députés pendant
une année il reste désormais attendre
les résultats de l'audit financier sur
le prêt de 3 millions d'euros 540000
euros ont déjà été remboursés par le
parti et après ces révélations Claude
bartholon a souhaité lui clarifier les
règles sur les finances des groupes
parlementaires il a d'ailleurs donné une
mission à deux questions dont Bernard
Roman je vous propose de l'écouter
ce qui nous semble essentiel c'est que
nous sortions d'une situation où on ne
peut pas contrôler les choses donc il
faut à la fois que les membres du des
groupes politiques puissent contrôler ce
qui se fait à l'intérieur de leur groupe
et il faut en même temps qu'il y ait un
regard extérieur objectif sans doute
d'un commissaire aux comptes sur la vie
des groupes
justement un instant sur les finances
des groupes parlementaires c'est le zoom
de la semaine
Bruno bottella est avec nous pour nous
dire ce qu'il sait de tout ça vous êtes
rédacteur en chef d'acteurs publics
auteur du livre petit secret et grands
privilège de l'Assemblée alors il y a eu
bonjour il est beaucoup de mesures
annoncées ces derniers temps par Claude
bartholone pour plus de transparence et
finalement on découvre encore des choses
comment est-ce possible ont l'impression
que ça avance au gré des affaires oui
c'est ce qu'on constate à chaque fois
c'est que il faut une affaire il faut un
scandale pour que les choses avancent or
le fonctionnement de la maison Assemblée
nationale est bien connue des députés la
maison il faut le savoir et gérer quand
même par un collège de questeur il y a
le bureau
au nom de la séparation des pouvoirs
l'État par Bercy ou bien la Cour des
comptes même certifie juste les comptes
mais ne vient pas au lycée jusqu'à
présent pour empêcher tout ça ça c'est
le premier point c'est à dire ça avance
par un coup au gré des scandales et ça
c'est un peu dommage parce que ça oblige
du coup à trouver des solutions rapides
bon
en dépit vous le dites des efforts de
transparence qui ont été faits on a vu
notamment l'effort de transparence fait
sur la réserve parlementaire par exemple
la deuxième chose qui me frappe c'est
quand même on parle de millions d'euros
et
on découvre cette occasion là que
c'est sont des sommes qui sont versées
chaque mois au groupe parlementaire
versez chaque mois et qui sont mis sur
un compte par les groupes c'est comme ça
que ça se passe concrètement c'est à
dire que les groupes qui soient
constitués en association ou pas
reçoivent de l'Assemblée nationale sur
un compte et ensuite le dépense un peu
comme c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus de
contrôle de l'Assemblée nationale des
services de l'Assemblée nationale
sur les comptes des groupes ça moi je
trouve pas ça normal vous savez combien
vous dépensez vous par mois pour le
groupe partie socialiste
500 euros ce qui n'est pas suffisant
puisque je donne en plus ça m'a
Fédération des partis socialiste et je
donne aussi aux parties nationales par
le biais de son association de France
7000 € par an 7000 euros
parce que le groupe socialiste est
depuis très très longtemps une
association 1901 et tous les ans nous
avons une assemblée générale dans lequel
le Trésorier qui est Christian Bataille
rencontre de l'argent que nous faisons
de nos cotisations choqué parce qu'il
s'est passé à l'UMP navré de constater
qu'ils ne sont pas une association et
qu'il n'y avait même pas de thèse
trésorier donc effaré amusé de voir ses
collègues qui ont versé cotisations et
qui ne s'intéressaient pas ce qu'on
faisait parce que ils nous disons nous a
rien dit je suis pas certain que
beaucoup me poser la question
des députés mais c'est l'assemblée quand
même l'inverse le plus gros des
contributions au groupe
c'est de l'argent public c'est de
l'argent qui est versé chaque année qui
est versé mensuellement mais au final
les plus gros groupes touchent entre 3
et 5 millions je crois par an sont quand
même des soins importants 35 millions
c'est quand même le budget d'une petite
entreprise
et c'est effarant de s'apercevoir que
notamment le groupe UMP t'es même pas
constituant l'association c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a même pas une assemblée
générale il n'y a pas de commissaire aux
comptes pour valider les comptes
c'est-à-dire que le groupe fait ce qu'il
veut avec plusieurs millions d'euros ça
ce n'est pas normal mais je dirais que
c'est la responsabilité du groupe UMP
mais c'est aussi la responsabilité de
l'Assemblée nationale
des questeurs d'une certaine manière qui
devrait parce que on dit l'indépendance
des groupes mais l'indépendance des
groupes par rapport à qui c'est pas
l'indépendance du législatif par rapport
à l'exécutif on demande simplement enfin
le citoyen moi je m'exprime peut-être en
tant que citoyen me dit il faudrait
qu'on interne les services de
l'assemblée et un oeil quand même sur
les dépenses est-ce que ça reste quand
même dans la maison
ça peut être très bien fait par les
services financiers de l'Assemblée les
fonctionnaires de l'assemblée sont des
gens tout à fait respectables et qui ont
l'habitude de travailler sur les choses
confidentielles ils sont d'ailleurs très
bien payés pour ça et on peut imaginer
cette forme aussi et qui a un contrôle
extérieur que ce soit lorsque c'est une
association par un commissaire et on va
sans doute arriver à là il suffit il
suffit de prendre l'exemple sur ce que
le groupe socialiste fait depuis des
années et que tous les groupes le
fassent nous il y a aucun problème pour
rendre les comptes de ce qu'on fait de
l'argent
ça serait aussi une solution
qui vous ont choquées moi j'ai travaillé
essentiellement sur l'assemblée j'ai pas
travaillé sur le Sénat mais ça
fonctionne moi j'ai travaillé ce oui je
suis enquêté dans le cadre de mon livre
il y a maintenant un an et demi sur
l'Assemblée nationale mais sur je dirais
ce qui est choquant c'est effectivement
que des millions d'euros de l'argent ne
soit pas contrôlés c'est à dire que
l'assemblée verse une fois pour toutes
et après ne s'en soucie pas la deuxième
chose quand même qu'on a appris à
l'occasion de cette affaire alors
peut-être par naïveté de la part Bernard
à coyé c'est que les groupes lorsqu'ils
ne dépensent pas de l'argent et bien
peuvent se constituer une cagnotte et
ce qui oui alors ce qui scandaleisé
Bernard coyé c'est que lui il avait
constitué un petit trésor de guerre de
10 millions et qu'ensuite quand c'était
Copé il n'en restait plus que 6 millions
le scandale au fond c'est que les
groupes un groupe comme MP constitué 10
millions d'euros de cagnotte 10 millions
c'est 2 à 3 années de subvention versée
par l'Assemblée assez groupe pourquoi en
boule de la législature les groupes qui
ont accumulé ça ne le rendraient pas à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a des besoins
surtout je rajouterai que les petits
groupes eux sont obligés souvent les
députés sont obligées
des écologistes et les députés vers sur
leur enveloppe collaborateurs 1500 euros
par mois pour contribuer au groupe parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez sinon de gens à
embaucher enfin c'est un fonctionnement
qui n'est pas normal il faut que ça
change tout de suite c'est pas normal
attendez ils font pas non plus jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain combien
d'associations dans ce pays ont des bas
de soi parce que elles ont accumulé les
subventions municipales et qu'elle les
dépensent pas non plus faut pas faire
une différence entre les associations X
ou Y moi ça me choque pas qu'une
association de parlementaires constitue
une réserve après tout nous avons des
élections de manière régulière et nous
avons des problèmes sociaux si vous avez
des collabos qui quand vous avez vos
collaborateurs qui sont licenciés après
nous avons des primes à verser donc
je suis d'accord 10 millions d'euros je
sais que je le président Debré m'avait
semblait semble-t-il
vertueuses mais rappelons quand même
aussi pour que chacun soit pleinement
informé que l'Assemblée nationale a un
budget qui n'augmente pas depuis
maintenant plusieurs années merci
beaucoup pour nouveauté Merci à VOUS
abonnez-vous à nos questions on va
encore parler d'argent d'économie on va
ouvrir le dossier budget et c'est le
budget
c'est le budget de la division à
l'Assemblée le collectif budgétaire
suscite de vivre tension au sein de la
majorité frondeur comme loyalistes ont
voulu faire voter des amendements contre
la vie du gouvernement heureusement les
légitimistes sont venus en renfort ELISA
bertholonet
ils sont agacés les députés légitimistes
de la majorité agacé par les quelques
frondeurs qui veulent réorienter le
collectif budgétaire après de vivre des
bancs en séance le bras de fer a
continué jusqu'en dehors de l'hémicycle
on n'est pas député de droit divin
on n'est pas député comme cela dans une
relation directe avec le peuple et pas
plus de députés de droit divin qu'il n'y
a de président de la République de droit
divin nous avons tous été élus
finalement nous avons tous été élus sur
un programme ou un projet et le débat
que nous avons maintenant entre nous
c'est est-ce que la politique que nous
sommes en train de faire reste fidèle à
ce projet ou est-ce qu'elle a dévié de
ce projet plusieurs socialistes rejoint
par les écologistes et les communistes
veulent amender le projet de loi de
finances rectificative en particulier
sur le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi une vieille revendication qui
divise la majorité difficile pour le
président de faire régner la discipline
au sein du groupe toutes les majorités
depuis le début de la cinquième
République se sont fondés sur la base du
vote du budget et d'un vote positif et
donc c'est à ce moment-là que nous
constaterons les choses mais je le dis
pour tous les membres du groupe
socialiste qu'il ne peut y avoir qu'un
vote au moment où il faudra approuver le
projet de loi de finance et le vote pour
l'heure aucun n'a fait part de son
intention de voter contre le texte
verdict mardi prochain lors du vote
solennel dans l'hémicycle alors on en
saura plus mardi avec ce vote
est-ce que Manuel Valls aujourd'hui joue
sa crédibilité sur ce collectif
budgétaire non parce que le vote sera
évidemment positif ce qui est agaçant
avec ses collègues oui évidemment mais
non évidemment jamais aucune d'ailleurs
aucun des votes qui n'est intervenu n'a
monté une fragilité la majorité est
majoritaire comme rédige Jean-Pierre
Soisson dans les années 60
a été voté personne n'a voté contre et
donc très honnêtement avec le bruit
qu'ils font ils devraient être 150 moi
ce que je raccroche ce que ils font trop
de bruit ce que je reproche à ses
collègues ce n'est pas leur conviction
elles sont évidemment honorables
respectables je ne leur reproche même
pas leurs amendements je trouve ça
cohérent c'est constitutionnel ce que je
leur reproche c'est qu'une fois qu'ils
les ont présenté ils demandent des votes
c'est à dire qu'ils espèrent construire
d'autres majorité vous savez il y a des
traditions dans les assemblées c'est ce
qu'on appelle les amendements d'appel
c'est des amendements qu'on dépose de
façon à engager un débat mais au final
parce qu'on ne veut pas porter atteinte
à la famille dans laquelle on appartient
on retire l'amendement pour éviter un
vote donc c'est le comportement
sont dans un groupe personne n'est force
ne force personne n'assister dans un
groupe quand on a l'air dans un groupe
on accepte les règles communes ces
règles Bruno Leroux les rappelle toutes
les semaines nous débattons entre nous
il y a même eu des votes au sein du
groupe socialiste ces votes ont été
unanimes unanimes que des collègues
fassent comme si ça n'existait pas je
trouve que c'est manqué de respect pour
le nom pour le groupe là ils deviennent
une difficulté pour le groupe parce que
ils on a le sentiment qu'en gros il y
aurait une masse qui ne serait pas
éclairée qu'il serait complètement
abatti qui serait entravée qui n'aurait
pas le droit de penser et puis il y
aurait un petit groupe qui lui serait
éclairé toucher du doigt de Dieu qui
serait ainsi illuminé et qui devrait
montrer la responsabilité sortir
non qu'il se qu'il se limite à ce qu'ils
font qu'ils sont des députés socialistes
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été élus parce
qu'ils avaient un point et la rose parce
que le groupe leur a apporté leur
soutien et parce qu'ils respectent les
règles collectives ce qui m'agace c'est
que justement il foule ses règles au
pied vous écoutent pas et qui continuent
à vouloir faire bande à part vous leur
dites il y aura dans toute collectivités
le vote du budget et le vote fondateur
on ne s'abstient pas sur un budget mais
si ils le font non mais on ne
s'abstiente pas ce sont des élus ce sont
des militants politiques ils sont pour
où ils sont contre ils s'abstenir c'est
de ne pas avoir d'avis il m'a semblé
qu'ils en avaient un
il vous semble et mardi on verra bien
voilà voilà des collègues éminemment
respectables encore une fois dont je
comprends même une partie des combats
qui qui essaie de convaincre à
l'intérieur du groupe il n'y parviennent
pas qui viennent dans l'hémicycle qui
dépose avant aucun État d'opté
l'amendement essentiel de cette semaine
a obtenu 31 voix socialeistes bon et
bien une fois qu'ils ont fait cela de
deux choses l'une où ils ont a perdu
leur conviction où ils acceptent se
plier la discipline du groupe mais il y
a pas de je sais pas ça existe pas c'est
oui ou non juste une petite question
Jean-Vincent placer que vous connaissez
certainement le président du groupe des
Verts dit dans une déclaration vouloir
un référendum ou une de dissolution
après les élections régionales il dit
plus rien ne tient que la majorité ne
tient plus que votre impression votre
réaction pense que Jean Vincent placé à
une conception étonnante des
institutions de la Cinquième République
elles sont là elles sont faites pour
durer et on peut d'ailleurs en mesurer
l'utilité et vous savez quand je vois
les comportements de mes collègues et
quand je vois le Sénat je me dis que si
mes collègues réussissaient on aurait le
Sénat c'est-à-dire une majorité qui est
délicaissante et qui n'arrive pas à
adopter des textes on y vient le Sénat
examiné cette semaine le projet de
réforme pénale largement amendée par
rapport à celui de l'Assemblée nationale
on voit ça avec Quentin calmé
séance nocturne hier au Sénat le Palais
du Luxembourg attend la garde des sceaux
connus pour son éloquence à son arrivée
Christiane Taubira se montre détendu et
fait même une entrée théâtrale
et le discours de Christiane tobira
prononcé sans note est à la hauteur des
attentes Clémenceau de Gaulle Badinter
la ministre de la Justice multiplie les
références historiques jusqu'à cet
hommage à Bertol Brest et Brest
à la douce violence de la raison à la
longue personne ne peut lui résister
merci
depuis hier la majorité avance en front
commun et soutient le projet de loi de
son côté l'opposition dénonce l'examen
précipité en procédure à accélérée selon
Philippe Bas le texte n'apporte rien au
contraire le signal est vraiment
détestable dans une société qui est
marquée par une violence croissante on
donne le sentiment de baisser la garde
c'est une loi qui comporte de bons
sentiments mais on ne fait pas de bonne
loi uniquement avec des bons sentiments
de même qu'on ne fait pas de bonne
littérature uniquement avec de bons
sentiments
principal enjeu la contrainte pénale la
mesure phare instaurée par le texte de
Christiane Taubira la commission des
Lois du Sénat veut aller plus loin que
la garde des sceaux en la rendant
obligatoire pour tous les petits délits
l'atmosphère très sereine pour le moment
dans l'hémicycle pourrait alors se
tendre entre la majorité et le
gouvernement donc cette contrainte
pénale qui est au cœur du débat a été en
commission des lois beaucoup plus forte
que l'Assemblée nationale notamment sur
les peines de prison pour les petits
délits sont allés trop loin les
sénateurs oui parce que c'est même plus
que la commission des lois le Sénat a
adopté quelque chose que je ne partage
pas ce texte il a il s'appelle renforcer
l'efficacité des sanctions pénales donc
nous le partageons sénateur et député
nous avons un désaccord sur un principe
une bonne sanction est une sanction qui
est adaptée à la gravité de l'infraction
et à la qualité de celui qui vient de la
commettre donc c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que nous avons supprimé les peines
plancher parce que ce sont des peines
aveugles peu importe qui peu importe
quand peu importe quoi il sait comme ça
on paye non il faut pour que la sanction
soit pédagogique pour qu'elle puisse
faire justement ce travail qu'on leur
m'attend c'est à dire que la
compréhension il faut qu'elle soit
adaptée or nos collègues sous la
responsabilité de Jean-Pierre Michel
viennent de nous dire non la contrainte
pénale est automatique et bien non je
suis pour l'individualisation des peines
donc nous allons voir nous allons nous
voir où vous le savez une commission
mixte paritaire le mardi ça sera le
mardi 8 juillet à 10h30
elle sera à l'Assemblée nationale nous
allons évidemment rapprocher les points
de vue parce qu'il faut aboutir mais le
point d'aboutissement ne peut pas être
le texte du Sénat et vous êtes confiant
par rapport à cette commission toujours
d'abord parce que ce sont des amis
jean-Pierre Sueur et puis Jean-Pierre
Michel que je connais bien leur
conviction je connais leur souci
d'émancipation je sais aussi leur souci
du réalisme donc la commission mixte
d'aboutira mais pas sur la base du Sénat
et donc vous allez imposer parce que
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui est le
dernier mot non pas dans la CMP dans la
CMP nous sommes 7 7 et bien nous allons
convaincre vous allez voter nous allons
devoir beaucoup nous avons déjà commencé
à et cette stratégie des petits pas
aboutira à une satisfaction qui ne sera
pas le texte du Sénat compter sur la
force de votre persuasion je crois la
qualité des rapports entre les deux
rapporteurs Jean-Pierre Michel et
Dominique grimbours qui se connaissent
bien et parce que nous sommes soucieux
de renforcer l'efficacité nous avons
besoin d'un texte qui a pas de texte on
repart pour une période que nous n'avons
pas le temps de conduire donc nous
voulons aboutir avant le 25 juillet la
CMP est prévue le 8 juillet elle
aboutira si elle devait pas aboutir la
République a prévu dans sa constitution
le dernier mot soit l'Assemblée
nationale mais je souhaite pas placer
nos travaux dans cette perspective là je
cherche
les chemins sont construits pour qu'ils
se rejoignent bien compris le message
jeudi une autre réforme qui vous
concerne et qui a beaucoup de mal à
passer
coup de théâtre au Sénat l'UMP le Front
de Gauche les Radicaux de Gauche se sont
alliés pour faire repousser l'examen de
la réforme territoriale le Conseil
constitutionnel est saisi les sénateurs
contestent l'étude d'impact de la loi
les sénateurs résistent encore une fois
on en écoute quelques-uns
nous sommes rendus compte qu'en fait il
y avait beaucoup de manquements
qui normalement devrait guider une étude
d'impact sur un texte comme celui-ci qui
est quand même un texte majeur pour
l'avenir de notre pays il est normal que
le Sénat soit soucieux de la démocratie
parlementaire il n'est pas normal qu'un
texte d'une telle importance
soit examinée dans de telles conditions
avec une procédure accélérée ce que j'ai
envie de dire à mes chers collègues que
je respecte beaucoup chers amis parlons
du fond on peut toujours faire des
argucides faire de la procédure retard
retardèrent encore mais ça ne fait pas
avancer le débat d'idées d'un centimètre
et comme vous le disiez ça retarde
l'examen de ce projet de loi est-ce que
vous avez un doute sur que le fait que
cet examen de cette loi sur la femme
territoriale arrive avant la fin de la
session extraordinaire à l'assemblée
a dit qu'il souhaitait que ça arrive et
que le gouvernement a les moyens
honnêtement je pense que c'est une cette
initiative sénatoriale dont je peux
contester la vocation politique parce
que c'est une manœuvre politique ça
n'empêche que sur le plan
constitutionnel président de la
commission des loyers comme un tout
petit peu sensible c'est passionnant
c'est la première fois qu'une assemblée
depuis la révision de 2008 saisit le
Conseil sont les études d'impact c'est
la première fois que le Conseil va avoir
à se prononcer sur les études d'impact
donc je ne doute pas qu'il aura
d'ailleurs les deux regards
que va-t-il faire sur le fond et que
fait le sait que fait le conseil d'une
déclaration enfin d'une étude d'impact
donc c'est constitutionnellement
passionnant sur la fin qu'est-ce qui va
se passer on va perdre un peu de temps
et puis évidemment mais du temps la loi
ne pourrait ne pas être examinée oui
enfin il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se repousser y compris les
délais des sessions extraordinaires donc
on peut obliger les sénateurs à essayer
jusqu'au mois d'août par exemple bah
pourquoi pas bien sûr quel est le
calendrier pour dire clairement les
choses vous dites que ce texte très
honnêtement je ne sais pas parce que ça
dépendra que d'une part du temps que
prendra le conseil il a huit jours
peut-être ira-t-il plus vite et je ne
connais pas la nature de sa décision
imaginons qu'il censure s'ils sont sûr
quelque chose qui paraît anodin et bien
il y aura pas de couleur
si c'est lourd oui mais est-ce qu'on
repart devant le Conseil d'État je ne
sais pas est-ce que le gouvernement
estime qu'il fallait directement devant
le Sénat je ne sais pas donc il y a
beaucoup trop d'incertitude pour
malheureusement c'est pas par souci vous
êtes désagréable mais c'est par volonté
d'être précis quels sont les chances que
ce texte soit examiné avant la fin du
mois de juillet avant la fin de la
session parlementaire je vous repose
avec en première lecture par chaque
assemblée maximale les champs sont
maximales le gouvernement l'a dit et le
gouvernement a les moyens d'y parvenir
ça veut dire aussi vous l'avez précisé
qu'on pourrait repousser la fin de cette
session en tout cas si nous devions être
dans cette situation je serai de ceux
qui demanderaient à ce qu'on repousse
oui la session extraordinaire qu'on
avance dans le temps encore pour que le
Sénat puisse en être saisi les sénateurs
a jusqu'au bout du travail bien sûr donc
jusqu'en août bien sûr c'est l'intérêt
des sénateurs je crois qu'il plaide
souvent pour que on les présente comme
étant la chambre des territoires et bien
qu'ils aient donc un avis sur le fond il
y avait un travail en commission des
lois enfin par an qui est en commission
spéciale puisque c'était pas en
commission des lois sous la
responsabilité de Jean-Jacques guest il
y a un travail qui avait été fait des
amendements avaient été voté
il était consensuel notamment autour du
Poitou-Charentes
13 régions au lieu de 14 mois avec le
Poitou-Charentes Limousin et Aquitaine
oui mais enfin je suis je suis pas élu
de ces régions mais en tout cas
l'assemblée il m'a semblé justement que
les parlementaires issus du
Poitou-Charentes étaient plutôt enclins
à se rapprocher de l'Aquitaine plutôt
que de se rapprocher de ce que le
gouvernement avait imaginé vous êtes
prêt à faire des concessions sur
certains points du texte notamment ce
fameux droit d'options dont Manuel Valls
ne veut pas entendre parler qui permet à
certains des départements de se
rattacher il faut vraiment c'est pas ça
c'est une question de c'est une question
de temps c'est une question de temps le
le chantier est en deux états il y a une
étape là sur les fusions de région parce
que le Président de la République a
souhaité que ça soit un périmètre
constant je pense que à ce stade il faut
pas de droit d'option parce que là on
ouvre une bataille ille qui devient
gigantesque puisque ça concerne plein de
départements mais au moment où nous
discuterons des compétences c'est-à-dire
à l'automne oui le droit d'option là
sera utile l'occasion d'en reparler
vendredi la question de la famille et de
retour à l'Assemblée
le débat en première lecture de la
proposition de loi a repris là où il
avait été arrêté examiné un texte pour
mieux définir l'autorité parentale et
protéger l'intérêt de l'enfant notamment
en cas de séparation des parents
Jean-Jacques ourvoise cet examen suit
son cours mais il y a une un arrêt très
important qui vient d'être rendu par la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
encore elle sur la question des enfants
nés à l'étranger de mère porteuse est-ce
que vous n'avez pas peur que cette
question là Vienne s'invite à nouveau
remarquer que la commission des lois est
extrêmement sollicitée
d'abord le gouvernement a dit qu'il ne
faisait pas appel devant la grande
chambre donc c'est une vision qui est
définitive ensuite ça ne pose aucune
difficulté en France la gestation pour
autrui est interdite c'est interdit au
nom de l'indisponibilité du corps cette
décision ne remet absolument pas en
cause le droit français donc la GPA est
interdite en France et elle restera
interdite en France durant cette au
moins on ne voit pas le dossier non
c'est fini oui mais que faire de ses
enfants qui sont nés de mère porteuse à
l'étranger
ils ont une nationalité la circulaire de
Christiane Taubira du mois de janvier je
crois règle les CK pour l'essentiel et
donc il ne faut pas essayer de chercher
dans la décision de la CEDH qui concerne
des enfants qui sont déjà très âgés et
qui ont une nationalité et en faire un
prime politique le problème politique
c'est la GPA en France dans ce
gouvernement faut-il en faire la réponse
est non nous ne modifierons
cette question est derrière nous la
commission des lois a décidément
beaucoup de travail vous allez
auditionner début juillet Jacques Toubon
il a été mercredi
il a été pressenti en tout cas par le
Président de la République il a été
proposé pour devenir Défenseur des
droits est-ce que vous craignez cette
audition déjà d'une part est-ce que ça
pourrait fournir au députés PS qui
peuvent qui ne veulent pas déjà tout bon
une sorte de camouflé au président de la
République un peu de frais le président
de la République a proposé Jacques
Toubon pour être nommé défenseur Jacques
Toubon sera Défenseur des droits il n'y
a pas de match
il n'y a pas de match parce que pour
empêcher cette proposition il faudrait
réunir une majorité des trois cinquièmes
des commissions des lois de l'Assemblée
et du Sénat pendant la révision
constitutionnelle en 2008 avec d'autres
j'ai dit bien souvent que cette
ce seuil était inaccessible il est
inaccessible même si tous les députés
socialistes du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
avec tous les députés communistes tous
les députés Verts et sénateurs votaient
tous contre Jacques Toubon on ne serait
pas au 3/5 donc il y a pas les matchs
exactement sera Défenseur des droits
d'où l'importance de son audition parce
que sans audition de mercredi ne sera
pas sur qui et Jacques Toubon mais que
fera Jacques Toubon comme défenseur des
droits et celle-là que nous l'attendons
à l'aune de position discutable qu'il a
pu prendre par exemple je vais vous dire
comme président de la commission je suis
très choqué que quand il était garde des
sceaux il est souvent bafoué les
propositions du CSM en matière de
nomination c'est à dire qu'il y avait
des propositions je ne m'en tiens pas
compte
un problème pour lui pour son c'est un
problème sur sa conception de
l'indépendance et donc comme il va être
Défenseur des droits j'ai besoin qu'il
prenne des engagements dans ce domaine
voilà pourquoi je ne crains pas
l'audition je veux la prépare même avec
beaucoup de Constance j'ai d'ailleurs
invité mes collègues à le faire tout
autant
deux fois au téléphone il pue il rédige
en ce moment les réponses à un
questionnaire que nous lui avons envoyé
qui était extrêmement fourni dont nous
publierons les réponses lundi matin de
façon à ce que voter les spectateurs
puissent eux aussi en prendre
connaissance ça fera deux jours avant
l'audition tout ça sera passé
ah j'attends l'audition j'attends
l'audition bien sûr on a compris on va
ouvrir une page mémoire c'est la
tradition dans cette émission pendant la
Grande Guerre les députés vous ne le
savez peut-être pas mais ils ont
continué à siéger c'est le plus de
l'hebdo
l'assemblée s'est associée au
commémorations de la Première Guerre
mondiale une exposition présente la
place et le rôle tenu par la Chambre des
députés c'était la 11e législature de la
Troisième République 1914
1919 le Parlement est donc resté un lieu
de débat Sarah Fargeot dans les couloirs
de l'Assemblée un parcours inédit
l'histoire de la Chambre des députés
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
compte rendu de séance une de journaux
et documents originaux les 600 députés
ont siégé presque 11 discontinuer
pendant 4 années de guerre tous réunis
derrière un homme le président de la
Chambre Paul Deschanel inventeur des
comités secrets des comités secrets
permettaient au parlementaires
d'interroger le gouvernement
le ministre de la guerre sur le
déroulement des combats sur la façon
dont la politique de défense était menée
pendant la guerre la chambre continue
donc de siéger avec des centaines de
textes adoptés et des bancs parfois un
peu vides 200 députés sont partis au
front soit un tiers de l'hémicycle en
août 1914 ils sont mobilisés les députés
sont mobilisés quand ils sont en âge
d'être mobilisés comme n'importe quel
français il n'y a aucun aucun privilège
lié à la fonction début 1915 les députés
mobilisés ont le choix retourner siégé
ou rester au front 60 d'entre eux
décident de rester comme Maurice
bokanovski son petit-fils a retrouvé ses
photos télégram et correspondance de
guerre pendant ces deux ans de combat
Maurice Bokanowski va se battre mais
surtout de venir informateur de la
Chambre des députés souvent les
collègues de l'Assemblée ne comprenaient
pas et lui reprochait de ne pas être à
l'Assemblée d'aller au front choisi ce
que tu veux faire mais justement il a
choisi d'être de faire le lien et de
voir ce qui se passait sur le terrain
Maurice Bokanowski retrouve
son chanceux cesse de ses collègues ne
reverront jamais le Palais Bourbon
les députés ont fait leur travail malgré
la guerre assurant la continuité de
l'État est-ce qu'on peut parler de
parlementarisme de guerre j'ai découvert
tout ça très honnêtement je connaissais
pas cette période j'ai regardé
l'exposition j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait 10 députés du Finistère nous
sommes 8 aujourd'hui puis ça renvoie une
question personne qu'est-ce que j'aurais
fait dans des situations comme ça comme
sur la période de la guerre 39-45 où je
me demande toujours qu'est-ce que
j'aurais fait est-ce que j'aurais
résisté ou est-ce que j'aurais fait
comme beaucoup j'aurais rien dit donc je
suis très admiratif et je vais passer le
peu de temps pour lire cela ce qu'ils
ont ressenti mais quand même quelle
force quelle gravité de se dire que
député de la République ils vont
combattre où il reste là c'est un
déchirement enfin ça doit être terrible
comme vous pouvez voir à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sera au travail jusqu'à la
fin de l'année ouverte au public merci
beaucoup Jean-Jacques urbaz d'avoir
répondu à toutes nos questions on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine avec
plaisir merci à vous pour votre fidélité
à très bientôt ciao ciao bonne semaine